bonjour ça dit elle qu'elle bonjour sa
mère madame ça dit elle qu'elle vous
êtes entre ocre la présidente fondatrice
du sommet mondial des femmes dans
l'industrie manufacturière 4.0 et vous
allez conduire une délégation canadienne
composée d'entreprises québécoises à la
deuxième conférence sur l'industrie 4.0
qui se tiendra en face du maroc le 27
janvier prochain et ce sera en mode
virtuel à cause de la pandémie
avant d'aller plus loin dans demain le
crel qu'est ce que l'industrie 4.0 en
fait l'industrie 4.0 elle est appelée
également quatrième révolution
industrielle
après celle de la mécanisation celle de
la production de masse et celle de
l'automatisation
c'est une démarche d'utilisation des
outils numériques dans un contexte de
continuité par rapport à la probabilité
la digitalisation ça prend une
révolution des compétences permet
d'élever le niveau de compétence de
certains salariés et de supprimer toutes
les fonctions article valeur ajoutée
mais également de réduire les tâches
pénibles et répétitive ça veut dire la
révolution et numérique s'accompagne
d'une révolution organisationnel
culturel de fait le succès de la
transformation digitale d'une
organisation repose avant tout sur les
hommes et les femmes qui la composent
écoutez quand on vous entend parler ans
dit vous allez en finir avec l'emploi ça
va être des machines et des usines à
100% automatisés c'est est ce que c'est
vrai ça ou c'est juste une vue de
l'esprit
ben comme je mentionnais c'est vraiment
notre mutation va éliminer les taches
qui n'a pas de valeur à moindre valeur
c'est pour cela on veut le chercher et
vraiment de l'ingénierie la technologie
donc c'est des emplois très très nommée
rue d'airé et puis ça va être vraiment
dans le cadre de préparer une relève à
high tech
donc normalement cette usine elle
elle nous apporte beaucoup plus donc
voir que d'en supprimer
vous allez participer à cette conférence
avec une délégation bien sûr la
conférence sur l'industrie 4.0 à se
remettre de fès au maroc
qu'est ce qui fait qu est ce qui attend
les participants étant une citoyenne
active et engagée mon objectif ultime
est de connecter mon pays au monde de
contribuer à propulser et de faire
rayonner les entreprises québécoises et
canadiennes du secteur industriel sur la
scène internationale alors techniquement
cette conférence très intéressante pour
y participer qui a pour but de
promouvoir l'économie et l'économie
résiliente et aussi de regarder l'emploi
minutes il a travers l'industrie 4.0 est
de voir qu'est-ce qui sauvait avec le co
vide que c'est un passage obligatoire ce
qu'un accélérateur vers la
défiscalisation
donc on est très honoré de participer
comme invité d'honneur et comme
partenaire aussi des officiels de global
industries 4 à 0 conférence qui a un
rôle de 27 janvier à fès au maroc sous
l'égide humeur du royaume du maroc et le
ministère de l'industrie du commerce de
l'économie verte et numérique
vous êtes à la tête d'une délégation
d'entreprises canadiennes du québec
comment vous les avez choisi et c'est
quoi vous ne déferle expertise
québécoise dont l'industrie 4.0 ben
encore une fois je suis fière
d'organiser cette délégation est
d'emmener avec moi une poignée forte qui
est la fierté du québec et la commune
des entrepreneurs manufacturés à lider
une automatisation et je salue monsieur
yves dandurand qui est président at
phase qui est très connu
madame lise déziel le président de
cordée électrique
il est lauréate industrie 4.0 de mon
dernier sommet 4.0 féminin
monsieur steven polidoro président face
à plastic une très belle entreprise
aussi automatisé dans park en joue et on
a aussi monsieur eric lepine les
spécialistes ont sonné du tri 4.0 le but
de cette délégation c'est tout à fait
clair pour ouvrir les possibilités des
changes
à travers l'industrie et d'expertisé
expertise québécoise de la technologie
on sait que l'afrique commence à se
préparer pour la digitalisation et
l'industrialisation
ce n'est qu'un début d' échanges de
délégations entre le maroc et le canada
d'autres projets des chansons concours
pour les pays du maghreb et de l'afrique
donc je voulais juste pour ce n'est
qu'un peu les injustices qu un acte est
une agence internationale qui organise
les délégations interindustriel et qui
créent et gèrent aimé honneur des
événements d'envergure mondiale dédiée
au service du manufacturier en vue de
promouvoir l'industrie de demain et ses
différents métiers
à l'ère du numérique et d'une
intelligence artificielle mais comme
l'écrit rythme nous on s'attendait à ce
que la copie 19 et un impact négatif sur
vos activités mais là on voit que vous
continuez à faire vos activités
habituelles c'est vrai que vous vous
déplacez plus physiquement ou le fait
d'une façon virtuelle
parlez-nous de l'impact actuel et futur
est ce que ce que vos projets futurs
sans chambouler s qui est ce que vous
allez en parce que ça va crescendo à ce
que ça diminue on voit bien vous écouter
sur ce point là c'est une très bonne
question et puis mes confrères et mais
conserve à partir de ce qu'il s'est
passé à l'échelle mondiale et on sait
que l'événementiel c'est le secteur qui
a été le plus touché effectivement en
événements ça a été reporté pour cette
année mais j'avoue que par expérience
c'est une très belle année pour moi
parce que ça donnait la possibilité de
se réinventer et c'était une belle
occasion pour voyager à travers le monde
virtuel on conférencière internationale
de faire rayonner le sommet de faire
rayonner l'industrie os 4.0 et
l'industrie au final comme ambassadrice
donc et on voit réellement que on a pu
quand même organiser délégation virtuel
et s'était passé donc je pense que
l'avenir est prometteur et le co vis de
nous aux précieuses et nous on sait que
c'est un passage obligatoire et c'est un
accélérateur vers cette technologie et
vous avez déjà un programme futur est ce
que vous les mêmes
né ou est ce qu'il a été échangé pour
vos activités alors là je travaille au
niveau virtuel pour les délégations
comme conférencière mais là je prépare
le sommet mondial 80 c'est vous cette
fois ci c'est à greentech c'est ça va
être en automne prochain
et c'est s'est toujours maintenue et on
va voir la possibilité c'est ça ma fille
bridoux virtuel c'est les comics qui
nous a valu nous rassure et ça mais pour
voir la possibilité mais sinon mon
agenda est toujours bien remplie et
d'aller de la merci beaucoup c'est
lequel je rappelle que vous êtes
on troque la présidente fondatrice du
sommet mondial des femmes dans
l'industrie manufacturière 4.0 et vous
allez conduire une délégation canadienne
pour la conférence sur l'industrie 4.0 à
fès merci beaucoup merci encore une fois
pour l'invitation